[Music]
this is an okapi
they may look like zebras but they are
actually the only living relative of
giraffes
endemic to the democratic republic of
congo the okapi is a solitary animal
that lives only in dense forests
their coloring is distinctive
their deep red coat contrasts with black
and white markings across their hind
side and legs
these specific markings act as
camouflage among the trees
similar to giraffes okapis have long
tongues that they use to pull leaves
from branches
their tongues are between 14 and 18
inches in length
so long that they can clean their ears
and eyes with it
the okapi are known for having
incredible hearing
their large ears can detect the
slightest disturbance around them which
helps protect them from predators it is
believed that in the last decade okapi
populations have been halved due to
deforestation and hunting
the presence of armed groups in their
native habitat makes conservation
efforts nearly impossible but local
governments are stepping up the okapi is
a fully protected species under
congolese law and is a national symbol
for the country
this is an okapi
[Music]
[Music]
this is aspen
a two-toed sloth
[Music]
sloths spend almost their entire lives
hanging in trees and do nearly
everything upside down
eating sleeping mating even giving birth
since it spends so much time upside down
a sloth fur grows in the opposite
direction of all other mammals this
allows water to run off the sloth when
it rains
its fur also has minute grooves that
collect and grow algae giving wild
sloths a greenish tint and providing
excellent camouflage
a sloth's powerful claws are perfectly
adapted for gripping and climbing trees
but become a nuisance when on the
ground surprisingly though they are
excellent swimmers and have been known
to drop into the water and swim to a new
tree
despite these adaptations sloths face
many threats
their forest homes are increasingly
becoming fragmented making breeding
difficult
and they are a popular target for
traffickers in the illegal pet trade
this is the two-toed sloth
this is howard he's four months old he
lives in california with his family duke
is his mom
domino is his dad and boo is his sister
they are pileated gibbons
this species is found in thailand
cambodia and laos
in the wild they are threatened by
habitat destruction and the wild animal
trade
they live mostly in trees and all
gibbons have strong arms and legs
the long muscular arms help them move
through the branches with impressive
speed
romantics by nature pileated gibbon
couples are usually monogamous often
staying with their partners for life
gibbon couples form strong bonds
grooming each other and hanging out in
trees
both males and females are similar in
size and have a cooperative family
dynamic
families do everything together and when
the children are grown they leave to
create their own families
[Music]
baby gibbons learn how to grasp their
mother's hair from early on and will
nurse for the first two years of their
life
howard hasn't started swinging on his
own yet but he'll be ready to start
learning soon
this is the pileated gibbon
[Music]
meet mawson and tingora
two adorable dingoes
no these aren't pet dogs they're
actually wild animals
dingoes are australia's wild dog
considered a cultural icon
but due to interbreeding pure dingoes
have become harder to spot
hence both mawson and tingora's similar
appearance to domestic dogs
dingoes are thought to have been
introduced to australia three to four
thousand years ago
they are australia's largest terrestrial
predator
dingoes hunt everything from rodents and
birds to larger prey like kangaroos
they are a big part of aboriginal
australian culture
yet are seen as pests by livestock
farmers due to perceived attacks on
animals
hunting for their skin and interbreeding
has left their population vulnerable
this is the dingo
this is cruz
he's a malayan taper
and he is hungry
[Music]
malay and tapers are the largest of the
four species of taper and are the only
one native to asia
a close relative of the horse and
rhinoceros tapers have poor eyesight but
their sense of hearing and smell are
finely tuned
if threatened or frightened they've been
known to demonstrate pretty quick bursts
of speed
they are also excellent swimmers and
will seek refuge from predators in deep
water while using their flexible nose as
a snorkel
although they are vegetarians they can
also defend themselves with a bite from
their razor-sharp teeth
[Music]
their distinctive black and white coat
looks very smart and also serves as an
excellent camouflage
predators will often mistake a taper for
a large rock when they lie down to sleep
despite these adaptations tapers are
extremely threatened
deforestation and encroaching human
development like flooding from
hydroelectric projects are all threats
to their shrinking habitat
this is the malayan taper
[Music]
this is bertha
she's a lima more specifically a
cockerel's shafak
while all of madagascar lima's a rare
she's unique even for her kind
there are over 100 different types of
lemurs in madagascar but none quite like
the cockrell shifak found only in the
northwestern forest of madagascar
sherfox moved differently than most
lemurs they stand on two feet and use
their powerful hind legs to leap up to
30 feet in a single jump
their beautiful fur also distinguishes
them
their cream-colored bodies feature
maroon patches
bertha loves her peanuts but shafaks
aren't picky eaters they consume
everything from leaves and flowers to
bark and deadwood
biologists estimate that less than 10
000 remain in the wild as major habitat
loss and hunting continues to increase
this is the [ __ ] rules shafak
[Music]
this is bambam he's a babaroosa
yes that is a real animal
a member of the pig family this
prehistoric looking creature is native
to the small indonesian island of
sulawesi
in males the upper canine teeth grow
straight up through the flesh of its own
snout and curve back towards their eyes
[Music]
as they get older the tusks can get
spectacularly large and on rare
occasions have grown so big as to pierce
their own skulls
babarus spend much of their time
foraging for food eating everything from
roots leaves and fruits to meat and
grubs
his strong jaws are easily capable of
cracking the hardest of nuts
in its native island home the babarusa
has no natural predators but
over-hunting and conversion of their
rainforest habitat to farmland has
reduced their wild population to less
than a few thousand
this is the babaroosa
[Music]
this is tammy and lucio
they're tamandawas
and this is their first date
[Music]
when a tamandawa feels threatened it
will rear up on its hind legs and use
its sharp powerful claws to slash out
sometimes it can be hard to break the
ice
tamandewers are the smaller cousin of
the giant
and while both species enjoy snacking on
ants tamanduas are excellent tree
climbers while their larger relatives
prefer to stay firmly on the ground
tamandas have excellent defense
mechanisms for enemies both large and
small if a predator gets too close the
tamandua will release a powerful stinky
spray four times as strong as a skunk
and its thick coarse fur keeps angry
ants from reaching its skin when dining
at an ant hill
despite these protective adaptations the
temanua remains a threatened species in
their native central and south america
habitat loss and hunting are both
looming threats
this is the tamandawa
[Music]
this is zayna a matchy's tree kangaroo
she's adorable isn't she
but don't let her adorableness deceive
you this rare kangaroo is extremely
threatened
with curved claws and stocky muscular
limbs she's at home in the trees
however her padded paws allow her to
fall from up to 60 feet without injury
this marsupial is so rare it can only be
found in the mountainous rainforests of
northeastern papua new guinea
it's a solitary creature that spends
most of its time alone
except for when there's a baby to care
for
tree kangaroo joeys spend 18 months with
their mothers before setting out on
their own
oil drilling and logging are destroying
the matchy's habitat and its thick
beautiful fur has made it an attractive
target for native hunters
captive breeding and local education
efforts are making headway
but its future is
uncertain this is the machi's tree
kangaroo
[Music]
you